the eu in the u.s were opening our
borders to them
experts are saying there's a clear
public health risk by doing that
why does the government think otherwise
well first of all we've double
vaccinated 70
of the adult population here so we're
confident as we
uh come out of lockdown in this country
that we're in a much stronger position
and of course it's only in relation to
those who've got an fda approved
double vaccination from the us and
indeed it applies to ema approved double
vaccinated people from the eu
it is part of the uh shore-footed steady
easing out of
lockdown and of course that includes
international travel for economic
reasons for various other things
yeah but what about those pesky variants
we don't know they're here until they're
here and then
countries like hungary they use the
saino vaccine
are you comfortable with that well we've
said that they would have to be
us fda approved double vaccinate double
vaccines or ema and neither those two
vaccines that you described have been
authorized
by those regulators so actually i think
that demonstrates we've looked at this
very carefully
and as far as the variants are concerned
but we keep an eye on the variance but
because of the
70 percent double vaccination of our
population
because we're insisting only people from
the us the eu and
perhaps in due course as we build up
confidence in the system other countries
we proceed on that basis because it's
people that are double vaccinated we
believe we've got the right level
of security and assurance against people
who might uh
be at risk of the variant coming in from
abroad any other countries in particular
that you're looking at at the moment
well it's interesting so already
overnight i've had foreign ministers
message me saying
we've noticed the announcement what can
we do to do this on a reciprocal basis
i think the key thing about the eu
countries in the us they're countries
where we're
we've got high trust in the mechanism
for verifying double vaccination
those are the kinds of countries that
we'd want to pursue in the future
okay like i'm not going to speculate at
this stage but what i'm saying is that
high trust countries
precisely for the reasons you gave i'm
not going to divulge all the details
that
all i'm saying is that actually uh what
it's done is encourage a conversation
reciprocally
about how british nationals british
businesses as well as international
businesses can come and travel safely
and i think as we
proceed out of lockdown we start to
think about international travel
that's the safe steady way of doing it
with high trust
countries where we can verify the
vaccines that their nationals have had
in order to come into this country spain
must be uh
tearing their hair out there because
they were on the green list and they
were on the amber
plus list now they're likely to be on
the amber watch list
it's very confusing for people who just
want to book a holiday with the kids it
is i totally
understand that this is a period of
uncertainties we come out blocked and i
think we're getting a little bit ahead
of where the jbc and the decision will
be next week but of course what we want
to do is one open up and
uh with a minimum inconvenience for
people but we've we've just got to be
totally vigilant for all these different
permutations of the variants
in exactly the way you described kay so
potentially it's moving you just haven't
decided yet
well i can't rule things out that the
jbc and the government will decide but
they'll make that decision next week
in terms of the traffic light system for
all the relevant countries but i think
personally feels like the momentum
forward is positive
because as i said because the double
vaccination
reaching 70 percent of the adult
population in this country we've done
the job we had to do
domestically and as we see other
countries catch up if you like
i think we're increasingly confident
that more countries will go
uh to to on the either on amber or onto
green okay
so just just to clarify people are
thinking about booking a holiday to
spain you're saying
well you'll know next week what the
latest what if you have to book it
tomorrow
you have to judge it on the basis of the
uh traffic light system we've got in
place right now we we can't give
uh cast iron guarantees about what the
next review system will decide if if if
we did
it wouldn't be a very meaningful review
system it's not a no then
um you said don't get ahead of myself um
is the prime minister getting ahead of
himself
because he's saying or august the 16th
no more quarantining if you're double
jabbed
and he says it's nailed on i thought you
went with data not dates
well we said um as we came through the
road map and we came to step four
that come the 16th of august we would
take that step
i think what he's demonstrating is none
of the data is pushing against
relaxing that easing up of the
test and trace system for those who are
double vaccinated
it also reflects not just the levels of
transmission and what we know about
the link between cases and
hospitalizations but it's also again we
come back to that key point k
we've got 70 of the adult population
double vaccinated that's what gives us
the assurance that is data-led
okay so why do we not do it now
rather than on the 16th of august
because one of your scientific advisors
who came up
um with the jabs and and his name is sir
john reed just for the benefit
of our viewers medicine professor at
oxford
he says um it's causing so many problems
this lockdown quarantining if you will
whatever you want to call it
and actually daily testing is the way
forward we are doing
daily testing but i think the the answer
to your question why do it now not in
say two and a half weeks time it's just
we know we can project how many people
broadly
we'll have double vaccinated and that's
the level of reassurance we want to get
to
i know it's been frustrating i know it's
been an inconvenience there's been lots
of things in this pandemic
that have been inconvenient but the
truth is the whole tide
whether it's domestic restrictions
international is going in the right
direction of opening up but we do need
to just be careful
make sure we do it at the right time
yeah but you know i mean the bottom line
is
we're allowing foreigners in the country
uh but we're keeping brits locked up
well i i'm not sure we're keeping brits
locked up two million
two million well it's not quite locked
up is it well you can't leave home
well uh what would you describe look
the the reality is if you're double
vaccinated come the 16th of august
all of that test and trace will not
apply of course people coming into this
country all of those rules around
test and trace would apply anyway so
there's no double standards here
but of course we've got to keep a tight
grip on what's happening domestically
um 16th of august is the point at which
with the level of the vaccinations we
feel comfortable
releasing that it's only two weeks away
and of course
there's always the goldilocks syndrome
where people some people say we're going
too quick
some people's too slow i think what it
demonstrates overall
is the trajectory out of lockdown the
trajectory of easing up
is sure footed steady irreversible
evidence-based that's the way we've got
to go
the um chairman of pwc accounting has
said that if young people don't return
to the office
soon that they will be blighting their
careers do you think they will
well i think with young people and the
way employers speak to their employees
we should use sensitive language
i think young people have borne a huge
brunt during this pandemic i know
talking to
students young people who have graduated
going into the
job market and i think what we want the
message we want to send is that
in terms of going back to work yes of
course employers will take these
decisions but we want to encourage
people
uh and we want to uh give them the
reassurance and the confidence to go
back to work
certainly that's the i think the message
the government wants so do you think his
words were insensitive well i haven't
seen the whole context but
but i certainly um i i certainly think
that we should be encouraging young
people to get the vaccine
making sure the workplace is a covered
secure confident environment for people
to return to
and certainly i know this as an employer
in the scdo and i've got a huge network
internationally as well as domestically
what i want to do is build up confidence
um rather than if you like take a stick
approach and say you've got to get back
into the office
because people are still feeling their
way and people have understandable
anxieties
i think we are in a position to give
reassurance and that's where the focus
should be
further um google netflix among others
are saying that staff need to be double
jab before they return
to work in groups do you think that's a
good idea we
want everyone to be double jab we want
uh but should it be a rule that you
can't go back to the office until you've
been double jabbed and then you're
protecting others as well as yourself
well i can understand why employers
think that that would be a smart policy
uh or approach to encourage whether or
not they should be
hard and fast legal rules i think we
need to look at carefully but our
message is overwhelmingly
um get the jab we've got a uh
we we've announced um uh the first batch
of 100 million doses that we're uh
we're distributing abroad to get the
world vaccinated
in a second um but i think it shows you
we will the message
in this country globally is get
vaccinated life gets back to normal
much more swiftly in a much more
confident way if people have got two
jabs okay
would you be content with uh that
proposal for
the fca that people would be double jab
before they came back to work
we're encouraging everyone to get double
jabbed and certainly
we've done that at post we've made sure
i think around the world
we've got as many people double
vaccinated as possible um
of course you've got to look at the
individual circumstances there may be
health reasons why people don't i'd want
to be quite sensitive about that
but for those people that can't get
vaccinated for health reasons it's
probably a different set of
considerations that apply anyway
we're giving um lots of vaccines away uh
countries like jamaica um and the like
and also
kovacs um is that because we don't want
them no we
uh at the start of the pandemic when we
did our vaccine program we
we secured multiple sources and supplies
and
overall the volume of vaccines to make
sure we had security of supply
that's why our domestic rollout has been
a success we've always said when we had
security and certainty
in our domestic programme we could start
giving more we've already given a huge
amount
through kovacs through the financing of
kovacs but we can
now through domestic supply give start
to give the 100 million
which will get the world vaccinated
we've got moral reasons for doing that
you look at jamaica laos
cambodia some of the countries kenya
that we're vaccinating we
feel a sense of moral responsibility but
we also know bluntly
that we are safer when the rest of the
world is safer whether it's for people
going on holiday or whether it's
just the ordinary course of
international trade that we need and we
rely on
so we're doing this for more reasons but
frankly we've got a big stake in making
sure we get the world vaccinated
and at the g7 the big thing the pm did
was encourage
um an extra billion doses to go into
kovacs and that international effort and
the reason we want to do that is we want
to get the world adequately vaccinated
by the middle of next year rather than
on current trajectory the end of 2024
think about what that means not just for
us but for those countries
massive difference that's why we're
doing what we're doing and to that end i
mean people think when they think kovacs
they think that it is for
countries that can't necessarily afford
the vaccines themselves wealthier
countries are
adding to that if we see countries like
canada part of the g7 taking from kovacs
does that leave a nasty taste well i
don't think canada would be eligible to
receive from kovacs
i think i think what you're describing
is is the supply chains going
into kovacs look canada is a really
close partner we're working with them on
all this they were great at the g7 on
all of this but let's be very clear
kovacs is overwhelmingly the criteria
going for the poorest countries in the
world and if i may just say
um at the point of the g7 95
of the kovacs distributed vaccines going
to those poorer countries were
astrazeneca which was produced at cost
with 90 million pounds of taxpayers
investment that shows you this country
what we provide as a force for good in
the world not just in terms of
vaccinating our own people
but uh the most vulnerable countries
around the world that's what we're all
about
why do you think we can travel around
the world again as soon as possible it's
part of my bread and butter but as i
said whether it's with the double
vaccinated reciprocal
arrangements whether it's the amber list
which will the traffic light
list the amber the green list of
countries they'll be reviewed next week
we'll get there we won't get there in
one fell swoop we'll get there
incrementally steadily that's the safe
way to do it